I don't think you understand how much of  an honor this is for me when I was 15 I  saw um i'ma got the movie did it with  the CIA and Harrison Ford I'm so sorry  I'm blank beetle and it's back a beetle  launched back with Harrison Ford you  blew my mind you you you were the  epitome of class you were everything I  ever wanted to be as an actress and I  mean the way that you battled those  politicians and then the military brass  men it was it was captivating was my  first Hollywood film I was a little lost  Sydney [ __ ] was really nice but  sometimes I didn't understand what I was  saying so I was too shy to ask but  fortunately Harrison was there to help